es ist weihnachten lassen wir uns also
bitte an die denken denen es gerade
nicht so gut geht ja ich rede vom
leverkusener bayer-konzern meine damen
und herren
die bayer-aktie neulich noch die
wertvollste im dax hat seit dem sommer
ein drittel ihres wertes verloren jetzt
geht so langsam wieder bergauf weil der
konzern 12.000 stellen abbaut
ein grund für den absturz bei hat
monsanto gekauft wissen sie die firma
monsanto vom image her irgendwo zwischen
kalli drogenkartell vw und saudischen
kronprinzen ja nur nicht so beliebt in
den usa drohen monsanto und damit bayer
gigantische schadenersatzforderungen
wegen glyphosat dabei ist glyphosat
eigentlich ein geiler wirkstoff weil er
natürlich auch eine besondere
aufmerksamkeit weil er so oder so
relativ vorzüglich ist der ist so toll
der wirkstoff da ja das einfach macht
spaß glyphosat macht einfach spaß und
schmeckt auch kalt auf brot liebe
zuschauer
monsanto und bayer meinen das übrigens
ernst glyphosat sei gut für die umwelt
weil man weniger flügen muss dass dabei
dank monokultur ganze ökosysteme
verschwinden inklusive unsere insekten
ja das ist schade aber irgendwas ist
immer
in den usa muss monsanto an einen an
krebs erkrankten mann 78 millionen
dollar zahlen
78 millionen und tausende klagen warten
noch in europa darf das zeug leider noch
mindestens vier jahre gesprüht werden
und schuld ist wir erinnern uns hier wie
heißt der noch mein nein der nicht
geschätzt der kollege schmidt sagte das
nicht wird für ca der ehemalige
landwirtschaftsminister hat sicher
entgegen der absprachen in der regierung
dagegen ausgesprochen
insgesamt zu verbieten so christian
schmidt oder wie in enge freunde nennen
glyphosat â das war ja der riesen
aufreger letztes jahr aber unsere
aufmerksamkeitsspanne ist als publikum
leider begrenzt und so kriegt kaum einer
mit in diesen tagen dass der ärger
weiter geht um glyphosat die
umweltministerin bilder erzeugt gerne
vor 2022 vom acker kriegen was wiederum
die landwirtschaftsministerin voll doof
findet [ __ ] vereint wir müssen deutlich
mehr aufwand treiben um den einsatz von
glyphosat jetzt grundsätzlich zu beenden
und das wollen wir wie immer entscheidet
jetzt zuerst mit der presse zu reden
statt mit den kollegen im kabinett aber
das ist dann eben so
julia klöckner bekannt aus der ard
telenovela julia wege zum gift ja
es bleibt dabei manche wissenschaftler
sagen glyphosat wahrscheinlich
krebserregend andere sagen
wahrscheinlich nicht mein vorschlag
einfach so lange nicht sprühen bis man
das wort wahrscheinlich streichen kann
wahrscheinlich na ich meine damen und
herren gut was das insekten sterben
angeht muss man zugeben er hat da da
sind auch andere stoffe mit schuld zb
die noch gefährlicheren neonicotinoide
kurz seo nix im grunde ja flüssig
zigaretten pflanzen mit neo nichts
kontakt werden übrigens auch besonders
häufig angeflogen ein tabak ähnlicher
sucht effekt auf denen der name ja schon
hinweist die stoffe beeinflussen sie und
können dazu führen dass sie das eigene
nest nicht mehr finden oder dass sie bei
der partnersuche erfolglos bleiben und
es gar nicht erst zur nachwuchs zeugung
kommt traurig der zugedröhnte käfer
schafft es nicht mehr auf seine rolle
drauf
neo nixe machen impotent dumm und
süchtig klingt wie eine doku bei rtl2
fällt gerade hofft ja ja und für bienen
ist das zeug tatsächlich die klassische
einstiegsdroge jaja es beginnt ganz
harmlos mit leo nixon im nektar und wenn
man davon angefixt ist dann raucht man
irgendwann die blüten und wenn das nicht
mehr reicht fliegen die gestreiften
junkies direkt unter die sprühdose und
energien den stoff partitur und am ende
dieser drogenkarriere steht wie so oft
leider prostitution auf dem
ameisenstraße steht traurig traurig im
april sind zwar drei neo nächste
verboten worden aber viele andere werden
in deutschland stumpf weiter eingesetzt
die zulassung von pflanzenschutzmitteln
weiß auch nicht jeder basiert in
deutschland weiter auf studien die die
hersteller selber durchführen
das ist im prinzip so als ob man uli
hoeneß seine eigene steuererklärung
machen lassen zum vergleich und leider
werden diese studien der industrie nicht
mehr veröffentlicht und wenn dann so wie
hier bei der studie zu soll fox floor
aber zu viel lesen machte kopfschmerzen
da haben wir ja echt viel gelernt aus
der großen glyphosat debatten letztes
jahr
ich fürchte viele deutsche verbraucher
sind inzwischen völlig verunsichert aber
den kann geholfen werden herzlich
willkommen zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo liebe gartenfreunde unser heutiges
thema pflanzenschutzmittel was wären wir
ohne sie
ich verrate es ihnen gesund ich mache
mir spaß junge zuschauer aber fehle es
wird ja heutzutage total verzerrt
dargestellt zum beispiel hier orangen
mandarinen die habe ich früher immer von
meiner oma zum nikolaus gekriegt und
gedacht du geistige alte ziege dafür
steige ich die später ins heim aber
jedenfalls heißt es jetzt plötzlich an
der schale deren rückstände von
pestiziden oder stimmt gar nicht doch
klar ja ja das zeug heißt chlorpyrifos
das steht unter verdacht unseren
hormonhaushalt zu verändern
hatten sie ich zeige ihnen kurze
brauchen sie einen bh den brauchen sie
ja er ach was für ein theater hier zum
beispiel diese dortmunder grünen ja
direkt sich auch so furchtbar auf aus
reiner neugier machte ihm rätsel war sie
bei einem harten schmidt zum nachweis
von pestizid rückständen im körper dann
plötzlich doch das erschrecken dass
spuren von einem pestizid in meinem haar
also auch in meinem körper gefunden
worden sind
na ja und vielleicht einfach mal die
haare waschen user als cd ich mein eine
grüne hat gift auch der rübe
das beweist nur 1 nüssli ist doch
gefährlich muss ist und ich wusste es
die ganze zeit ja kommt mal wieder
runter auch diese hysterie wegen
glyphosat ich kann es nicht mehr hören
ja das ist völlig ungefährlich das kann
ich so auch unser studio publikum
springt passiert nichts waren sie mal
den mund auf die augen zu
einfach entspannen
so hatten sie nicht nur haare
tina ich finde schon sie verharmlosen
ein echtes problem
in deutschland werden 112 pestizide auf
äcker gesprüht deren zulassung
eigentlich schon längst abgelaufen ist
seit jahren bei einigen wissen wir dass
die nach heutigem stand der forschung
war richtig giftige gifte sind ja ja
aber da gibt es eine wunderbare
hintertür in der eu pflanzenschutz
verordnung und zwar artikel 17
wenn die behörden bei der prüfung des
verlängerungsantrag zu lange brauchen
dann läuft die genehmigung einfach
weiter wie verschiedene behörden prüfen
das bei uns und ich finde die machen
einen super job für eines der standard
zulassungsverfahren brauchte deutschland
statt der maximal erlaubten 120 tage
eine durchschnittliche zeit von 7 157
tage
ich sage immer lieber gründlich prüfen
bei der lindenstraße hat man auch erst
nach 33 jahren gemerkt dass die schäden
nicht zustimmen
oder hier das hier ist zum beispiel pen
die metall ihn das war schon verlängert
bis juli 2018 und wird jetzt wegen
lahmer behörden noch mal verlängert bis
2024 sechs weitere jahre gift für alle
was sollte das
ich finde es nicht in ordnung dass sie
das alles in unserem unschuldigen
publikum testen
die freuen sich und jetzt testen wir mal
ob diese dieselabgase wirklich so
ungesund sind wie immer alle behaupten
achtung und schon in viele ausnahmen und
bildern
[Applaus]
[Musik]